hello and welcome to co playing slow
German 438 night 89 I gotta [ __ ] felt
okay okay goes back okay would have
taken with the beep on this time I had a
saw an interesting idea yesterday in
this line by I think wasn't wrong jaan
the quick Bishop e3 ok so he definitely
wants to prevent if some default prevent
is strong it ok I had to do before
anyway I wanted to make sure that Bishop
g4 isn't happening maybe I should have
played you for anyway he has to take on
before the rook is hanging it will not
be five is the thing it could be it's
certainly a little bit of an annoyance
EFM let's see
97 twice now is a threat actually I
think
Jim not sure what you can do against it
maybe bishop is 69 a seven-night see for
things like that might be compensation
yeah this is a similarly no I can take
now right it's no big big thing this one
work here well here I can take we can I
didn't have to take
if I flame okay let's think about this
for just a moment it's attacking on beat
one on c3 yet and I probably don't have
much else them so let's do it this
should be too I wonder set a threat that
before might be possible I am Bishop b5
doesn't do much and then you can take on
between whom yeah it's not so clear how
I cover this home
huh not so good huh what you do here
don't see them something greater I would
like to keep the pole at least but I
don't see how rook be one gypsy
truenicks looks very strange very
strange Chaka Chak okay I'm returning
your pawn down the resulting position at
least a sir still a little bit easier
for whiter flame I hope maybe it's
that's not the case but we'll see I'm
simply a little bit more active there
look see a it is coming tell you better
go here and okay now group c 8 still
okay you may be wants to take still
don't have anything here I know okay
I want two day if I wanted a five here
he cannot take not sure I would actually
this help with anything but let's do it
I very assured I've gone look c7 them as
long as I had the opportunity to do it
anyway ok 95-97 blunders and I'm
threatening night 2 786 now maybe we
should be five this is kind of more woe
why is that possible ah night be three
has oh poor that's awkward ok one I
cannot play night be three
hmm
I'm morning yeah yeah yeah yeah what a
shame
what a shame
50 seconds mmm
you have improve a purely objective
point of view I think I'm okay but the
50 seconds are of course very much a
problem i have you should be eight aha
yeah this is the way to lose this stuff
of course I should okay check
try to the active fee as active as
possible which probably hurts me here
Jack now threatens was check stupid now
cash at a time probably i'll lose on
time anyway check check check check
check yeah night be three yeah he was
got saved by this move okay I'm checking
my letter Nate yeah night be three yeah
yeah I'm just better in this position
and pressing but i didn't i didn't see
that i didn't see that I thought this
and wins but he has this one this is the
thing in this position he is just
suffering actually rook c7 immediately
is good or night a seven is good yeah
pressing maybe it's the promise to draw
night 87 is probably probably right
a new system yeah that looks a lot
better from white but okay I was really
so exactly the line here and thought my
ideas no 97 at a six getting pressure
against this but he can take you had
this he saw that you can take and yeah
I'm still okay but yeah I've got them
I'm a minute down this just makes the
whole thing very awkward Oh f 6 was
something that I should have done that
would have made it a lot easier check
maybe maybe Jack this is also
objectively and I'm probably not yeah
yeah it's impossible to what is with the
time now it's also just lost position
yeah a bit of a shame very costly game
if you have him if you are the clear DJ
player and lose a better position it's
always very costly yeah I think I cannot
really blame myself that much I just
overlooked night this night be three
stuff and that that got me into trouble
with the time being low okay well thanks
for watching